[Música]
continúa en un hospital de Bogotá la
recuperación de los cuatro menores
colombianos hallados en la selva tras 40
días sin rastro el padre de los niños
denunció que ha recibido amenazas de
disidencias de la extinta guerrilla de
las FARC
la Casa Blanca confirmó que tiene
información de un centro de espionaje
del gobierno chino en Cuba esto luego de
que el diario de Wall Street journal
revelara que Beijing habría estado
operando una unidad de inteligencia en
Cuba durante años información negada por
la Habana
bomberos de varios países del Mundo
continúan batallando contra el fuego en
la provincia canadiense de Quebec hace
poco socorristas y bomberos franceses se
unieron a la difícil tarea de controlar
el fuego que ha dejado más de 4 millones
de hectáreas quemadas Solo este año
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Colombia donde continúa la recuperación
de los menores que permanecieron 40 días
perdidos en una selva del suroccidente
del país este domingo se conoció que la
madre de los menores que murió en el
accidente de avioneta que provocó que
los niños se perdieran en ese territorio
habría sobrevivido unos cuatro días de
otra parte del padre denunció que ha
recibido amenazas de disidencias de la
antigua guerrilla de las FARC que según
aseguró estarían tratando de sacar
provecho económico
y el país sigue deslumbrado por la forma
en que los niños sobrevivieron gracias a
una mezcla de saberes ancestrales
indígenas previamente conversamos con
Luis Acosta coordinador Nacional de la
guardia indígena de Colombia que nos dio
más detalles de la unión entre los
indígenas y el ejército para esta
operación de búsqueda una unidad que se
considera sin precedentes
importante también fue la alianza que
logramos hacer entre el ejército
y las y el movimiento indígena y sus
guardias indígenas creo que esta Alianza
es fue fundamental en el ejercicio de
poder
mantenernos con esperanza
compartíamos con el ejército
compartíamos comida compartimos
sabiduría ancestral y compartimos
conocimiento tecnológico creo que es muy
importante y fue de mucha importancia el
combinar estas dos sabidurías estos dos
conocimientos
Porque mientras unos nos guiamos con GPS
nos guiamos con con las ayudas también
tecnológicas y hacía perifoneos repartía
comida en la selva con los helicópteros
otros caminábamos en la selva bajo la
protección de los Espíritus de los
mayores y bajo la capacidad organizativa
de los pueblos indígenas
esta tos
formas de protección estas dos formas de
vida
permitieron que encontráramos la vida es
por eso que la alianza entre las fuerzas
militares y este plan Esperanza entre
fuerzas militares y y guardias indígenas
dio resultados y el resultado fue
encontrar los niños
encontrarlos sanos y salvos con
situaciones de desnutrición pero
poderlos encontrar es muy importante
podernos encontrar para compartir
sabidurías compartir conocimientos y
para mandar un mensaje de unidad y de
paz a Colombia creo que en estos
momentos de mucha incertidumbre en
Colombia es de suma importancia estos
estas alianzas estos reconocimientos
este apoyo en conjunto fue muy
estratégico esta Alianza entre las
fuerzas militares y la guardia indígena
para encontrar los niños
cambiamos de tema porque funcionarios
estadounidenses indicaron que tienen
información de un centro de espionaje
chino en Cuba desde 2019 la información
se conoce luego de que En días pasados
El diario de Wall Street journal
publicara que Beijing estaría operando
una base en esa Isla lo que fue negado
por el gobierno de La Habana incluso por
el pentágono veamos más en el informe
una declaración sin precedentes hecha el
sábado por un funcionario de la Casa
Blanca que deseo permanecer en el
anonimato confirmó un informe publicado
la semana pasada por los medios de
comunicación estadounidenses incluyendo
el Wall Street journal china está
espiando a Estados Unidos desde Cuba en
virtud de un acuerdo entre la Habana y
Beijing una base de espionaje estaría
establecida en la embajada
estadounidense estratégicamente ubicada
en la famosa Avenida Malecón frente al
Golfo de México permitiendo la
recolección de datos en Estados Unidos a
los 160 kilómetros
las autoridades cubanas niegan
categóricamente la existencia de este
acuerdo el Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores acusa a Estados Unidos de
especulaciones calumniosas pero para el
departamento de estado estadounidense
esta violación de la confianza
diplomática nunca impedirá que Estados
Unidos mantenga ya presencia diplomática
hay que recordar que la diplomacia no es
solo política también es mucha logística
se necesita personal se necesita
presencia tienes que tener un edificio
donde puedas poner en práctica esa
diplomacia hay muchas historias
interesantes aquí y tenemos la intención
de seguir participando
Este es un tema delicado en un momento
en que el presidente estadounidense
espera un deshielo en las muy tensas
relaciones con Beijing también es
negativo para dubaiden que está haciendo
campaña para su reelección en 2024 la
oposición le reprocha su de firmeza en
sus relaciones con China y con el
régimen comunista de Cuba en México el
partido oficialista Morena estableció
las bases para elegir al próximo
candidato de Cara a las presidenciales
de 2024 Andrés Manuel López Obrador no
puede aspirar al cargo por las normas
constitucionales Así que los esfuerzos
se centran en encontrar a su sucesor
Mario carbonel corresponsal en Ciudad de
México nos amplió los detalles
el próximo 6 de septiembre se conocerá
al candidato del partido Morena a la
presidencia de la república para
contender en las elecciones de 2024 Y
definir al sucesor de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador Así quedó establecido en
los acuerdos firmados en el Consejo
Nacional de este partido Morena el jefe
de la diplomacia mexicana El canciller
Marcelo ebrard es hasta el momento de la
firma de estos acuerdos el único que ha
puesto fecha para la separación de su
cargo En la cancillería a partir de este
lunes los otros aspirantes deberán a más
tardar el viernes 16 de junio de acuerdo
con lo establecido en estos acuerdos
ebrard incluso Ya dijo que ha recibido
mensajes con motivo de esta separación
del cargo de parte de su homólogo de
Estados Unidos el secretario del Estado
Anthony blinquen así como del secretario
de seguridad interior Alejandro mayorcas
y de otras personalidades de la política
como el expresidente de Uruguay José
Mujica así a más tardar el viernes 16 la
jefa de gobierno de la capital de la
República Claudia sheinbaum el
coordinador de los senadores de morena
Ricardo Monreal y el secretario de
gobernación Adán Augusto López deberán
dejar sus puestos el método de selección
de este candidato presidencial será a
partir de encuestas el partido Morena
llevará a cabo una encuesta central y
será acompañada de otras cuatro
encuestas espejo que realizarán empresas
profesionales sugeridas por los
aspirantes a partir de ahora ningún
gobernante o funcionario público debe
expresar apoyo por uno de los aspirantes
la encuesta se llevará a cabo entre el
28 de agosto y el 3 de septiembre de
modo tal que el día 6 de septiembre
habrá candidato presidencial morenista
en Canadá mientras los históricos
incendios siguen asolando la región de
Quebec personal de varios países sigue
llegando para ayudar a combatirlos entre
ellos bomberos y socorristas franceses
de Protección Civil tenemos los detalles
rodeado por una de las brigadas que ha
venido de Francia a echar una mano este
bombero de Quebec da las últimas
explicaciones
los bomberos y rescatistas franceses
vienen del sur de Francia para el jefe
de operaciones del destacamento esta
formación previa es esencial debido a
las condiciones locales específicas
Empezando por la extrema densidad del
bosque quebecense con pocas carreteras
de acceso Pero eso no es todo el otro
la otra especificidad es que no hay
puntos de agua no tenemos una reserva de
cisternas como en el sur de Francia así
que tenemos que adaptarnos a la multitud
de ríos de la zona
Canadá lleva varias semanas sumida en
incendios forestales históricos en el
oeste del país en la Columbia británica
y en la provincia de Alberta tras unos
días de tregua los incendios se
intensificaron de nuevo el viernes
provocando la evacuación de miles de
personas el sábado en Quebec mientras
que los incendios en el nordeste de la
provincia se consideran estabilizados la
situación en el nordeste sigue siendo
difícil cerca de 14.000 personas siguen
bajo orden de evacuación en la región
con la formación llegando a su fin la
ayuda de los bomberos franceses es
inminente en todo el país las
autoridades contabilizaron el sábado
416 incendios activos 203 de ellos fuera
de control con más de cuatro millones y
medio de hectáreas quemadas desde
principios de año
pinta el informativo ustedes Gracias por
su sintonía
[Música]